Deezy 62 is a yellow powder like
substance that can be found in a number
of locations across Washington DC most
prevalent in quarantine areas like the
dark zone
this chemical ended up being as toxic as
the doll flu itself but where did it
come from
and why was it released into the already
devastated streets of DC
[Music]
[Music]
with his Darwinistic views dr. Gordon
Amherst believed that the planet needed
a helping hand if it was to survive he
went on to create a new super virus with
the intentions of radically reducing the
human population the green poison or
dollar flu was based on the original
smallpox virus except that his new
strain would be more infectious incubate
faster and was considerably more lethal
on top of us the virus was designed to
survive for longer on non-organic
surfaces like the currency it was used
on to spread it out among the population
the dollar flu was also made up
containing traces from six different
pathogens like h1n1 swine flu and Ebola
people who caught the virus would
usually start to show symptoms within
the first three days similar to the
common flu which was by design this was
to deceive the population and medical
staff and allow the virus to continue to
spread before it was realized it was too
late the patient would then rapidly go
downhill dying within six to seven days
of first being infected but the ability
to recognize the virus before it got out
of control was only the first hurdle the
green poison was also designed to
rapidly mutate this made it extremely
difficult to find conventional drugs and
antibodies that were able to fight back
or even to create a new vaccine
altogether the ability to mutate also
allowed the virus to quickly adapt to a
diverse range of climates but it wasn't
all bad
Amherst deliberately meant for the virus
to have a mortality rate of 80 to 90
percent meaning that he did intend for
at least some of the human race to
survive nice guy
[Music]
initially the virus was thought to be
smallpox so inevitably the vaccines that
were distributed failed over time many
many different drug trials will run and
most had little to no effect on the
green poison one of the drugs named DC
62 showed promise but due to
insufficient testing it was uncertain
how much of an effect it would have
under pressure and rapidly losing ground
to the green poison government officials
gave an order to release the
experimental drug into the public at the
very least we start spraying in two days
in the meantime you can announce a new
program designed to stop the spread of
poison the first area in the city to
have DC 62 distributed was the wealthy
suburb of Georgetown Georgetown became
what we now know as duck's own West what
they weren't expecting from DC 62 was
that when it gets exposed to the cold
temperatures it transforms into a highly
toxic chemical agent in turn it became
just as lethal as the green poison
itself rather than being infectious like
the green poison DC 62 was extremely
toxic to breathe in and would cause most
people to instantaneously die out from
the lethal levels of toxicity
part of this could have been from the
rushed methods of rolling it out which
was to literally drive around with
barrels of the chemicals strapped to the
back of trucks with the lids removed
dispersing it around the streets DZ 62
turned out to be toxic to almost
everything it touched any items in
contact who would have to be completely
decontaminated before use the quarantine
zones across the capital were
established to contain the remaining
traces of the Dahl flu but after being
treated with this new cure they simply
became a no-man's land due to the high
levels of toxicity that could be seen
throughout the area's we know these
areas as ducks an east west and south
this new DZ 62 had left a path of death
across the concentrated areas of
Washington DC naturally hostile factions
that were starting to gain a presence in
DC saw an opportunity in this new
chemical at some point under the command
of Colonel Anton Ridgeway the true sons
managed to harvest the DZ 62 from these
contaminated zones and utilize it is the
primary ingredient for the chemical
weapons program
they would later put this to use
decimating the castle sediment leaving
only a handful of survivors and
rendering the settlement completely
uninhabitable for the foreseeable future
then again later when the black tusk
made the presence known and launched
their full invasion into Washington DC a
team of BTS who came across some DC 62
barrels and Jefferson Plaza the black
tusk managed to reverse-engineer the
chemical into a liquid form and had
plans to use this in their mission to
gain control of the capital however this
was quickly stopped by the strategic
homeland division I'll finish this up
with a short cinematic I'm not stating
anything I'm merely pointing out the
similarities yellow powder heavy residue
left behind highly toxic
is this a Sikh way towards a video I
have planned for the future maybe we'll
see
I generally try to focus on topics where
there's a lot of presence in the story
things that I can really sink my teeth
into and develop into an interesting and
depth video for people to watch but the
division also has a ton of smaller
topics that are quite intriguing and can
really glue the whole story together so
like this video I'll be popping these
smaller videos up from time to time with
the added advantage of perhaps being
able to release them a little more often
in between the large videos before I go
I keep getting told how weak my social
media gamers so here I am doing the
cliche YouTube thing of calling them out
to follow me on Twitter Instagram
discord tinder grinder etc you can find
the links in the description then you be
able to keep informed with my incoherent
ramblings dead jokes and possibly even
meet up for a good term thanks for
watching Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you